[Music]
and what about the teachers news what
about them diminished by Jack and Jill
Jack and Jill J Aiello and up the hill
or down the hill I'm Jack and Jill went
down the hill to [ __ ] pail of water
I like their version better LA County
school board members have received
controversial Ravus they've been needing
my life don't eat it Los Angeles school
teachers need they need a raise they
work so [ __ ] hard with the shittiest
kids in the world I was one of them you
know yeah okay LAUSD is [ __ ] up so the
members of the LA Unified School
District Board of Education compensation
review committee whoa man what's that
happen in like the LA us our tech 82
view yeah LAUSD b e CR see that's not a
thing [ __ ] BSD ABS a DM Club yes I
miss the arc as this committee they
agreed to give LA board members at the
teachers the members a hundred and
seventy four members that I lost uh no a
good 100 walked up I thought it was for
the teachers what is a hundred and
seventy four percent job all and then
another seventy percent on top of that
another yeah so if they made a hundred
they made a hundred grand with increase
of 174 the other make it to 70 Omega T
so I'm just curious how much are they
getting right now this is teachers this
is members before I got board members
teachers like I feel like when you've
been there like 10 years you can make
okay money like at least enough to live
like or whatever my friend's mom is a
junior high teacher she's been there for
a long time she makes six figures yeah
yeah yeah and then it depends on county
and city and then I think also if your
college obviously or even junior college
you can make some Bank my mom taught at
a private school for 20 years it got
paid like 20 percent less than even a
public school teacher
am really why does your mom work
nobody's quick trickle of the kids
yeah I don't know she try to teach our
quality students smaller classes and 100
cent so it's kind of like not easier but
you can it's not babysitting Plus
teaching
because the junior high that my friend's
mom works at it's like a really
dangerous you know losing her oh man
that's a terrible yes all right if
you're and this is 100% just judging if
you're it not well behaved and you're in
a less fortunate area in the same school
those teachers are going to get paid
less than a fortunate school so they're
doing with more horseshit and getting
paid less right because if you're at
like Beverly Hills Academy their taxes
and everything through the roof those
teachers get paid more and those kids
are probably [ __ ] also yeah but
maybe they're quiet dick I'm not like
carry weapons yet doing around Julian
loogie spit ball my coke yeah cocaine
their cocaine decay coke and Laguna
Frank Ocean I kind of different kind of
orange orange chant like at an orgy that
crashing their their Benzes into the
[ __ ] gymnasium yeah the board members
I have no other employment their pay
will go from forty five thousand six
hundred a year to 125,000 years forty
six gradual hundred what else and end of
the ones I do have other employment they
are going from twenty six thousand four
hundred two fifty thousand and that's
for part-time board made more membership
yeah so if you're a hard time now you're
making a picky 6k how do I get in as a
part-timer yeah what do I got to do like
Skype in on a meeting here in their name
at the board of education compensation
wasn't be reviewed every five years but
it hasn't been reviewed in the last ten
years because the last time they were
due for a review the economy was so bad
that they couldn't get a raise that's
the reason why they're kind of getting
double I think teacher raises happened
like that sometimes too like well we
can't do this you can't do it this year
can't do this year and then it like it
so um I am I see so they're they're
raise was long overdue so they've been
doing their job
yeah and twenty thousand for part-time
member seems like not much yeah but a
hundred and whatever the heck you just
said seems like a little much yeah I
think the hundred something is for
full-time now what's my amber do fifty
what the hell are these people do that
you know I want to read it that's why
board members and like the committee of
the school I just don't remember like
PTFE or whatever it's probably like some
[ __ ] like that
you know what their school see like the
school president they make Bank yeah
yeah
the compressor mobile pretty 800 in
college presidents college prep
university presidents make over they
came over hundreds of thousands of
dollars there's like a company CEO I'm
with you I wish I knew what
disappointing this is the only one time
for this whole time I've ever known you
that we're gonna agree yeah well they're
they're in charge of the entire public
school system so they're in charge of
like if any curriculum changes it would
go through the board members if there's
any like instruction or anything
anything about like the couple's yeah
that's that's a course [ __ ] though a lot
of these guys they've worked their way
up and they have PhDs and stuff so I
don't know if they're just getting paid
because of the amount of education at
what they really make that big of
difference so they might have been
teachers for ten years and then now
they're in a little council room like
this you just say elected to be board
members but that sounds then they go to
politics and some dog sure it is
politics with education I don't like
that maybe they make them right moves to
make the school bring in more students
let's hope so yeah I just I'm thinking
about whatever they do it's important
that's why they need to get paid that
much la so big but what's the general
consensus of la la school district it's
[ __ ] garbage yeah it's a jail system
yeah yeah I think that's kind of all
public right that's where everyone talks
[ __ ] well did you go to did you go to
close I want my mom taught at the
private school so preclusion future the
funny being we live like a block away
but I was a part of the Los Angeles
School District so my area wasn't that
bad but the kids that went there they
were like they got busted from the
outskirts your school was bad dude yeah
you guys didn't go to school though but
yours was bad too right like you didn't
go to the same house we went to the same
high school when I moved out here
because yours was bad you said yeah but
when I grew up in the South Bay I'm
living here no so this is how bad that
one or so I came from another area I
came from Cerritos yeah and that's a
pretty good school district I came here
and this school didn't even have
bathrooms on toilets so if you were
taking us you mean the bathroom door I
got them doors would be like apart
they didn't have bathroom doors so if
you're taking a [ __ ] someone needs to
come in and wash your hands they can see
like your dick and they're just sitting
there
why is that who got to like Banga doors
or broke it or maybe maybe they're like
smoking or [ __ ] Arnold is a yeah but
that's cool we're [ __ ] [ __ ] or
[ __ ] only two possible [ __ ] it yeah
there was no doors on about this school
was horrible by Jolla saying that this
was actually upgrade from the other UNC
like at least we had walls
yes dude when the bell rang at my high
school
like it was optional yeah people stood
outside whatever we had a police station
in our school with handcuffs like on the
on the chairs because they're probably
used alias every day you get there there
was a table for the officer there there
was two officers and they would ride
around in bicycles along with the
Rottweilers go-cart security people but
these are real like cops real cops in
the school yet and they had an office
just like a police station in the school
you guys always had like four or five
cop cars in front of the school like
every day I'm bike yeah yeah there's of
a station there kids just run around
with guns and whatever do you do with a
comment if somebody died at least once a
year yeah not joking yeah lovely the
Dodger game show we had yeah contrast
and can I hear your school I don't think
we had security the scariest things we
were on the river so there's a lot of
rattlesnakes that's not scary
that's really I was in a musical every
year
yeah those force hahahahaha so that was
the biggest problem that you guys faced
all the time in school so this gives you
an idea of how wonderful was it's pretty
like liberal like everyone's pretty cool
and they still want to make like a gay
pride group and there was not one gay
issue in the whole school and this guy's
like let we're just going to do it just
because well what is your school's name
it's a cold like a Rudolf Steiner school
or Waldo Waldorf someone's watching once
a Waldorf shout out and represent down
there in the comments uh Demi knew of it
she said it's more natural really it's a
liberal arts school yeah yeah it's like
a liberal art school yeah it's more
German based and then I think more
international more well-known than
America is it style of Education
different like whatnot yeah very
different they try to I talk to you a
little bit about it
they try to like teach you through
different pathways we're like a regular
school all you do is sit listen or read
I think I would have done great well I
think it gets a lot of [ __ ] talk space
for being like a Harry Potter school
because there is some weirdness I want
to learn magic I go to Hogwarts like the
Isaac so then it's good that's it I
can't
you should go teach there come on man if
you go teach there it's free maybe
that's a part-timer
owe me $20 on your [ __ ] it's lower
there's like there's like a
kindergartner something hmm just hang
out here then another curricular oh yeah
so they try to just teach you like see
people playing with play-doh uh no
because Plato's artificial well we play
with beeswax and I organic for real you
were close so you you like try to uh
hear something to learn it do something
to learn it and then like read and draw
something to learn it cool little
example we're learning like Roman
history or something and my teacher
would take us out in the like soccer
field and like March like Roman did you
go to my school I couldn't pay attention
for [ __ ] it's what I did and there's so
many studies like outside of this
schooling that say like kids aren't
supposed to sit at a desk for eight
hours kids aren't supposed to sit at a
desk I'm not a kid and I can't do that
now if a kid if kid moves around in the
morning and tries to learn or even human
in the fitness world if you move around
and then try to learn or learn and then
try to move around there's like
different pathways of learning and your
memory is increased which one's better I
forgot it's for different things though
I swear I read something like if you if
you learn something then run you'll
remember better but if you run and then
learn something you comprehend bender or
something like that no quote me how
about if you fight and then learn its
movement I'm sure it's in but but it has
to be like happy fighting like like rip
your hamstring and then go to work
fighting
Chris for real girl like after training
with Noah and doing a lot of martial
arts I feel like I'm a happier person I
wouldn't understand I think that's all
like a movement in endorphins and it's
better something about punching the [ __ ]
out of the bag and feeling like I'm
murdering somebody makes me so happy
yeah you might have other [ __ ]
and you're eating healthier too right
not real nah I hope you guys enjoyed
this video for more please subscribe to
our Channel and you can check out the
last video right here
[Music]